RUSSIA OVER THE POISONING OF A
FORMER SPY AND HIS DAUGHTER.
THE KREMLIN SAYS THE BRITISH
ACTIONS ARE TOTALLY ON
ACCEPTABLE.
SENIOR FOREIGN AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT AMY KELLOGG IS IN
MOSCOW TONIGHT.
>> THERE IS NO ALTERNATIVE
CONCLUSION OTHER THAN THAT THE
RUSSIAN STATE WAS CULPABLE FOR
THE ATTEMPTED MURDER OF
MR. SERGEI SKRIPAL AND HIS
DAUGHTER.
THIS REPRESENTS AN UNLAWFUL USE
OF FORCE BY THE RUSSIAN STATE
AGAINST THE UNITED KINGDOM.
>> HAVING HEARD NO CREDIBLE
RESPONSE FROM THE RUSSIANS ABOUT
THEIR ROLE IN LAST WEEK'S POISON
ATTACK ON BRITISH PRIME MINISTER
THERESA MAY ACTED.
SHE ORDERED 23    23 RUSSIAN DIP
SHE ORDERED 23    23 RUSSIAN DIO
SHE ORDERED 23    23 RUSSIAN DIA
SHE ORDERED 23    23 RUSSIAN DIS
TO LEAVE, EXPELLED FROM THE
UNITED KINGDOM.
HER FRUSTRATION WITH MARX MOSCOW
HER FRUSTRATION WITH MARX MOSCO
MOSCOW.
>> A MILITARY GRADE NERVE AGENT
IN EUROPE.
>> MEETINGS BETWEEN BRITISH AND
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS ARE OFFER NOW.
THERE WAS INCREASED SCRUTINY OF
RUSSIA.
THE RUSSIANS DEMANDED A SAMPLE
OF THE NERVE AGENT.
>> I SAID EVERYTHING DONE BY THE
BRITISH GOVERNMENT IS ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE AND WE CONSIDER IT
A PROVOCATION.
>> RUSSIAN DOUBLE AGENT SERGEI
SKRIPAL AND HIS DAUGHTER IN
CRITICAL CONDITION WERE POISONED
WITH A NERVE AGENT IDENTIFYING
WITH A NERVE AGENT IDENTIFYING I
WITH A NERVE AGENT IDENTIFYING E
WITH A NERVE AGENT IDENTIFYING T
WITH A NERVE AGENT IDENTIFYING F
WITH A NERVE AGENT IDENTIFYING E
WITH A NERVE AGENT IDENTIFYING D
WITH A NERVE AGENT IDENTIFYING A
WITH A NERVE AGENT IDENTIFYING S
NOVICHOK.
DEADLY CHEMICAL WEAPONS FROM THE
SOVIET UNION.
DESPITE RUSSIAN DENIAL, EXPERTS
SAY ALL AVENUES LEAD TO RUSSIA.
>> IT HAS TO BE UNDERWRITTEN BY
THE TOP AUTHORITIES IN THE
KREMLIN.
THIS HAS ALL OF THE OF
FOOTPRINTS ALL OVER IT OF
INTERSERVICE OPERATION AUTHORIZE
FROM THE HIGHEST LEVEL.
>> THE KREMLIN HASN'T TAKEN ANY
ACTION IN RESPONSE TO THE
EXPULSION ABOUT RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS SAY THEY ARE PREPARING
ONE.
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
A.B. PREOCCUPIED BY HIS VISIT TO
CRIMEA TODAY WHERE HE THANKED
RESIDENTS FOR VOTING TO REJOIN
RUSSIA.
BRET, THE U.K. CALLED AN
EMERGENCY SESSION OF THE U.N.
SECURITY COUNCIL THIS AFTERNOON.
THE U.S. AMBASSADOR NIKKI HALEY
SAID AMERICA STANDS BY ITS ALLY
AND BELIEVES RUSSIA WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ATTACK ON
BRITISH SOIL WITH A MILITARY
GRADE CHEMICAL WEAPON.
WE EXPECT TO HEAR MORE HERE IN